[Music]
thank you sir
et sat down with Michael Pena and Diego
Luna to talk about the upcoming season
of Netflix hit drama
narcos I don't think this is the fourth
season I think this is like a new
beginning going with a complete new cast
new story new country it even looks
different the fourth season moves the
action to 1980s Mexico telling the story
of undercover DEA agent Kiki Camarena
and Mexican drug lord Miguel félix
Gallardo's marijuana so you are playing
a real person Kiki died in 1985 but did
you feel pressure to really get him
right of course the ex-im I spoke to his
wife Myka come arena what was that like
you know she she gave me the impression
that she was a very strong woman and
that she supported him all the way and
she's the one who told me that he was
the kind of guy that just you know had
to do something about it and if not he
would just stay up it would keep him up
at night again
Lucas three and I mean Patti I had to do
a lot of research there was a lot of
information for me and I had to stop one
day and say okay this is it
now I'm gonna I'm gonna do my own
interpretation of this for me the most
important thing was to recreate that
Mexico the Mexico of the eighties the
Mexico I saw as a kid did you hear these
stories when you were growing up yeah
definitely I mean when the Kiki Camarena
okay it happened I was more focused in
the World Cup I have to accept yeah I
was six years old but I around 88 I
started to wake up so going back to
those days it's interesting yeah I'm
telling this story matters because to
understand the present we have to take a
look at the past and see what went wrong
and to raise the question you know like
how much are we all involved in this
that's important
[Music]
your character is dad you're a dad
how did being a dad in real life kind of
shape the way you approach this role
well you know what inherently it makes
you more cautious you know like even the
way that I Drive now is a little more
cautious like if he's in the car like
I'm definitely more cautious when I'm
not I'm like I'll kick it up to 35
exactly I'm crazy I drink a coke instead
of the doc hey I keep I keep going all
night you don't want any part of this no
but you get the feeling of potential
loss you know like you don't want you
don't want your kids to grow up without
a parent you know and so you kind of
take that into consideration whenever
you're close to danger or whatnot and
that's what I would think of when I was
playing certain you know certain parts
and certain scenes is that you know
think of think of the big picture and is
it worth it